pete after me no bodyguarding no
regarding the sequel builds on on the
first movie in a delightful way
sometimes it can be terrible because the
sequel just sort of exploit all the
great things about the first movie and
then
reiterate them again this movie doesn't
do that it sort of hijacks the tone
and the sentiment in a great way but
gives
life to so many more new um and wild
elements what is he doing here
i said can anyone but michael rice
i believe it's pronounced thank you i
just thought there was an interesting
angle of this guy who's like taking a
a sabbatical from all any and all
violence like will not touch a gun
uh we'll only carry pepper spray and
there's something great about uh
you know being in this kind of high
octane action film where sam's character
is an assassin so naturally he is
carrying weapons and guns all the time
has no problem with it
you know it's just totally integrated
into his personality but my character's
kind of at odds with it all the
connection between ryan and i
you know only gets better because you
know the more time we spend together the
more we know about each other the more
we
we love hate each other in a way that
you know
makes sense and uh hopefully people will
come in and buy into that again i
promised my therapist no bodyguarding
let's not do that guys let's just focus
i got it no it's fine you guys just you
guys have had him
maybe feather the break a bit selma
really brought something to the table in
the first movie that
needed to be explored and exploited
further and and
and i think i don't even think anyone
really talked about it was just a given
that she was going to be the
headliner of the second film in the
first movie i didn't
get to have any scenes with ryan and
it's just been such a delight um
like i said we improvised a lot together
and
he i really found myself
waking up really looking forward to
to the adventure of knowing what the
heck we were gonna do and say
and uh i have so much respect
for his talent this really feels like a
newbie